dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here this
piece of work is still in progress done
by one of the members of the Google
brain research team and several
researchers from the amazing New York
University the goal was to show a neural
network video footage of lots and lots
of fluid and smoke simulations and have
it learn how the dynamics work to the
point that it can continue and guess how
the behavior of a smoke puff would
change in time we stopped the video and
it would learn how to continue it if you
will now that is a tall order if I've
ever seen one most of this episode will
not be about the technical details of
this method but about the importance and
ramifications of such a technique and
since almost all the time our episodes
are about already published works it
also makes a great case study on how to
evaluate and think about the merits and
shortcomings of a research project that
is still in the works this definitely is
an interesting take as normally we use
neural networks to solve problems that
are otherwise close to impossible to
tackle here the neural networks are
applied to solve something that we
already know how to solve and the
question immediately comes to mind why
would anyone bother to do that we've had
the very least twenty episodes on
different kinds of incredible fluid
simulation techniques so it is
abundantly clear that this is a problem
that we can solve
however the neural network does not only
solve it correctly in a sense that the
results are easily confused with real
footage but what's more the execution
time of the algorithm is in the order of
a few milliseconds for a reasonably
sized simulation this normally takes
several minutes with traditional
techniques it does something that we
already know quite well how to do but it
does it better in many regards loving
the idea behind this work
training is a pre-processing step that
is a long and arduous process that only
has to be done once and afterwards
querying the neural network that is
predicting what happens next in the
simulation runs almost immediately in
any case in way less time than
calculating all the forces
and pressures in the simulation while
retaining high quality results it is
like the preparation for an exam that
may take weeks but when we are finally
there in the examination room if we are
well prepared we make short work of the
puny questions the professor has
presented us with I am quietly noting
that during my college years I was also
studying the beautiful navier-stokes
equations and even as a highly motivated
student it took several months to
understand the theory and write my first
fluid simulator this neural network can
learn something very similar in a matter
of days what a stunning and may I say
humiliating revelation note that this
piece of work has not yet been
peer-reviewed there are some side by
side comparisons with real simulations
to validate the accuracy of the
algorithm but more rigorous analysis is
required before publishing the failure
cases for classical hand crafted
techniques are easier to identify
because of the fact that their
mathematical description is available
for scrutiny in the case of a neural
network this piece of mathematics is
also there but it's not intuitive for
human beings
therefore it is harder to assess when it
works well and when it is expected to
break down we should be particularly
vigilant about this fact when evaluating
a task performed by any kind of neural
network based learning algorithm for now
the results look quite reassuring even
the phenomenon of a smoke puff bouncing
back from an object is modeled with high
fidelity there was a loosely related
work from the ETH Zurich and Disney
Research in Switzerland and enumerated
the differences is a bit too technical
for such a short video but I have
included it in the video description box
for the more curious fellow scholars out
there now you might have noticed the
lack of the usual disclaimer in the
thumbnail image stating that I did not
take any part in the project which was
not the case this time I feel that it is
important to mention my affiliation even
though my role in this project has been
extremely tiny you can read about this
in the acknowledgement section of the
paper needless to say all the credit
goes to the authors of this paper for
this amazing idea I am vision all kinds
of interactive digital media including
the video
games of the future being infused with
such neural networks for real-time fluid
and smoke simulations and let's not
forget that this is only the first step
we haven't even talked about other kinds
of perhaps learn about physical
simulations with collision detection
shattering glass objects and gooey soft
body simulations and we also have seen
the very first results with light
simulation pipelines that are augmented
with neural networks I think it is now a
thinly veiled fact that I am extremely
excited for this and this piece of work
is not the destination but a stepping
stone towards something truly remarkable
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
you
[Music]
you